j'aime beaucoup c'est pas la question
on a passé de très bons moments toi et
moi mais ça marcherait jamais parce que
je suis ta mère
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
qu'est ce qui s'est passé coiteux lucky
jil est un bon copain
ah oui c'est le monsieur qui s'habille
en clown c'est ça les gens vous
remarquez qu'il a disparu je fais pas le
con sable h en poupe
allô allô oui pas ses mots le conseil
des fantômes nationale tu te rends
compte que tu me demain la wii passe et
moi je conseille les fantômes s'il vous
plaît ok on a du boulot mais on a plus
de qui tu peux me rappeler ton prénom
c'est te plaît batman pardon j'ai une
cape segre gens les grappins tg j'ai une
batmobile la gueule ça va avec l'ont lu
arrête sa cure lui t'es sérieux et
roberto je vous dérange pas j'espère au
moins vous rien qu well and us ou
montrent qu est-ce que c'est ça ben oui
on arrête avec ça c'est du charisme
c'est une blague mais évidemment que
c'est une blague
connard tu préfères peut-être crever ici
ouais d'accord yannick
eh ben il est mort lors du chantier des
entrepreneurs de francs matricule
c'est vrai mon père parce que c'est ce
que tu bandes plus qu'honneur sortir à
sébeillon se confirme ouais que la force
soit avec la gueule pendant trop
longtemps kull bonne je vais t'aider
eh bien merci tu es trop chaud ah non
pas du tout non alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait alors est ce que tu préfères un
doigt non d'accord ouais j'ai mes règles
merde je crus mais bof bof
est ce que tu veux bien commun ça me non
allez au revoir
non vous avez du temps à perdre avec ces
simagrées oui oui non oui non oui non
oui non non non non non non et non
financiers ont arrêté deux buts un vrai
chien s'est vu que même à traiter
monsieur niveau bayard comment vous en
sentez va là où vous voulez aller 1
moi non plus
première si vous êtes 2 millions
d'abonnés
c'est vraiment énorme comme ma [__]
merci merci merci merci merci merci tout
le monde je pense un peu